my producer the reason I am here come
here this is the reason I am here this
is Jonathan who produced everything
everywhere all at once he is the reason
I have shown up here tonight oh I love
you I wouldn't make you feel it makes my
heart melt every time because we are
really a good true family and she's
she's our head cheerleader well I like
hearing see this is the reason why
Ariana Dubose said Jamie Lee you are all
of us
Jamie Lee who are all of us cause you
are are people giving her a hard time
what is happening I'm here with you what
is happening I don't understand it she
is fantastic and so full of life and
love and spirit I don't I don't I still
I've had a couple people text me and go
What's Happening Here I really don't do
you not understand it well I think it's
because number one when you saw the
crowd shots people seem to not get it
but I looked at it as she took that
moment to celebrate women everywhere
with the crowd shots
tell you all something
you're sitting at an award show and then
all of a sudden you don't know what's
about to happen
all of a sudden somebody with a thing is
like this close to you
and you're facing out they're right here
they're here and you're like you're
watching something you have no idea
what's going on why are they coming here
and then they you see the red light go
on right and then you're supposed to
well and what do you I mean anyway
exactly no but I get it well I like that
you appreciated the moment because she
probably needs to hear that appreciate
talent and that woman is Talent with a
capital T Jamie Lee who are all of us
speaking of Talent with a capital T I
heard uh this interview you did with
variety today and it seemed like you
were getting emotional because you were
saying Michelle yo is the reason I was
here I love hearing you speak anyway but
it really felt like number one it was
coming from your heart number two you
were getting emotional about that I if
we're not emotional I don't know what
we're doing
it's the arts arts are emotional
the the movies are emotional they are
they are supposed to elicit a response
an emotional response in you maybe in my
world fright and horror and in many
words love and and emotion if we're not
in an emotional state with each other I
really don't know why we're doing this
and I am in this movie because of
Michelle yeoh when my agent told me that
I was offered this part in this movie I
was told Michelle yo was in it I said
I'll do it and
that was three years ago in Simi Valley
for 38 days the fact that we are at
award shows and that I am nominated
along with my fellow castmates and
Michelle yo for an Oscar is directly she
is she is like the connect the dot not
the director is not lovely Jonathan who
you just met Michelle yo I love it you
know they're going to be auctioning off
the props for this movie how about that
let's talk about what real advocacy
looks like so a24 as a company
has auctioned I got an email hey we're
auctioning off everything and I was like
what do you mean everything they were
like everything I said what do you mean
everything and then they sent me the
thing
three Charities transgender Law Center
Asian mental health and the laundry
Workers Union
everything the rakakuni the the puppet
from rakakuni
I believe is at ninety thousand dollars
somebody's going to buy it for that
tells me a lot about the advocacy of a24
putting their money
where their mouth is where their care is
it's a beautiful beautiful moment of
advocacy did you think about bidding on
anything or did you just you know I have
a couple things okay you did take what
did you what'd you get
I might have a pair of hot dog hands I
also I actually have Deirdre bobedras um
like Hall Pass thing very good I love
that
foreign